dassault change de cap le fabricant
d'avions de chasse veut privilégier
maintenant le civil et l'espace à côté
du rafale on va travailler aussi sur
hermès et de tout nouveaux locaux
viennent d'être inaugurés à toulouse au
reportage olivier loubet à toulouse
dassault veut tourner la page ne parlait
plus d'atlantique de oud alphajet les
1400 70 employés des usines de colomiers
ont été reclassés tous ou presque tous
72 selon la cgt 40 selon dassault reste
sans solution
dassault maître d'oeuvre délégués sur le
programme européen cherche à
rééquilibrer son activité au profit du
civil est donc aussi du spatial et base
pour nous représente un objectif très
important nous avons pris comme des feux
environ 10% du chiffre d'affaires
d'environ 4% en ce moment à la fois par
le développement d'activités hermès et
aussi par d'autres activités
concrètement d'assaut en charge les
études et les calculs sur la définition
l'aérodynamique où la structure de la
navette européenne moyens de cette
ambition un puissant système
informatique
la compagne de ses ingénieurs s'appelle
katia logiciel trois dimensions outils
de dessin pour la conception et la
fabrication
deuxième axe de recherche la résistance
thermique ce sont les tuiles d'hermès
l'engin devra supporter jusqu'à 1700
degrés partout où il y à aile delta et
présence de l'homme en vols en haute
altitude d'assaut avant ce son
expérience et ses projets son staff en
dhr spatiale ou encore le star h avion
hypersonique qui préfigure peut-être le
transport futur à l'horizon 2020-2030
serge dassault veut voir loin comme pour
oublier un présent incertain